accent a été mis sur ce qui est le plus
important pour la population mondiale il
ne fait aucun doute d'une chose c'est
que c'est un accord qui sert le monde
c'est un accord qui permettra de
soulager les pays pauvres près de la
faillite cela permettra d'aider les
personnes proches de la famille de la
famille cela permettra de stabiliser le
prix des denrées alimentaires déjà à des
niveaux très élevés même avant la guerre
et ce qui représente un cauchemar pour
les pays pauvres et l'Union européenne
je vous le disais a réagi elle réclame
la mise en oeuvre rapide de cet accord
d'Istanbul sur les céréales on retrouve
shona Bata charia Istanbul bonjour
Shauna il faut le dire l'Ukraine a
longtemps hésité avant de signer cet
accord vous avez notamment des
informations en provenance de Kiev
oui notre équipe à Kiev a pu parler avec
un conseiller du président zeninski
Mireille podoliac qui a dit
au micro de France 24 qu'il était trop
tôt pour rassurer les populations
vulnérables notamment en Afrique que
l'Ukraine ne pouvait pas faire confiance
à la Russie et l'Ukraine qui menace
d'annuler l'accord si jamais la Russie
tirait même un seul missile vers Odessa
alors par ailleurs donc nous venons
d'entendre le secrétaire général de
l'ONU donc Antonio guterey et ce qui est
intéressant dans son discours c'est
qu'il a vraiment mis sur un même pied
d'égalité la reprise des exportations
ukrainiennes mais aussi l'exportation la
facilitation d'exportation des des
céréales russes et ses engrais et c'est
pour ça que c'est un important de
souligner que si au départ négociations
concernées principalement sinon
exclusivement les céréales bloquées en
mer Noire que la Russie que Moscou a
réussi à faire aussi accepter la
facilité de ses propres exportations et
que du coup c'est non seulement une
victoire diplomatique pour l'Ukraine
mais aussi pour la Russie une victoire
diplomatique également pour reggae père
douane la Turquie qui accueillait cette
cérémonie merci beaucoup Shauna on vous
retrouve bien sûr un peu plus tard sur
l'antenne de France